c'est donc la semaine de la rentrée des
classes le moment pour les parents de
choisir s'ils le veulent une activité
sportive un choix qui doit être
réfléchie selon les envies de votre
enfant bien sûr mais aussi son caractère
les sports individuels ou collectifs ne
véhicule pas les mêmes valeurs
aaron tan dit mathias baron braquo or
c'est pas toi sur le bord du terrain les
parents sont parfois les plus stressés à
la fin de l'entraînement c'est sûr les
enfants en auront plein les oreilles
mais surtout plein les jambes des poules
quoi au moins quatre à la maison il va
dégager d'or pour marc pas de problème
maillot de zidane sur le donne le ballon
lui colle aux pieds et puis le sport et
lui c'est déjà une longue histoire
en revanche pour mathias le football
c'est plus compliqué à 6 ans il faut
dire que pour son premier entraînement
tout le monde y passe devant
tu dis tu peux le faire assez pour
lutter contre un lourd passé le père
intervient pas question que son fils a
abandonné une carrière commencée
seulement quelques minutes plus tôt
peut-être au départ je vais un peu fort
c'est parce que j'aimerais bien qu'ils
se dégourdisse un peu on va dire et puis
si ça lui plaît pas on trouvera autre
chose alors pourquoi ne pas essayer le
judo premier contact avec le tata nous
meziane a choisi seul ou plutôt avec sa
maman d'enfiler l'autre simoneau pour
les parents difficile de faire le bon
choix selon le caractère de son enfant
et attention tu fais rouler voilà ça
c'est très bien pour tout ce qui est
humidité tout ce qui est art martiaux
c'est à dire c'est prendre confiance
dans son corps et dans sa force en
forcément devenir un violent pour tout
ce qui est enfin violent par contre là
je conseille je préfère des sports tels
que le rugby ou le football où là il ya
des règles sociales a respecté et où
l'enfant comprend que c'est pas
l'individualisme qui fait gagner une
équipe
mais au contraire le respect des règles
le respect des autres et le respect du
coach dans le club de levallois perret
l'escrim ça prend un petit pas sous le
regard d'une championne
laura flessel qui est un tour comme
s'est mise à rêver de cape et d'épée
on sait que c'est ce qui m'a amené à
l'écrit c'est zorro qui m'a emmené les
fronts j'avais pas c'est vrai j'avais
commencé j'ai commencé à votre âge
oui s'il existe oui lorsque je les vois
je me revois à 5 ans et demi et je me
dis c'est fou comme j'avais pas froid
aux yeux parce que là on regarde ils ont
du répondant et ils n'ont pas froid aux
yeux
il s'amusait puis n'ont pas peur du
ridicule donc c'est la joie de vivre
avec ça pas de panique si votre enfant
n'aime ni zidane nuit zorro il lui reste
plus de 150 disciplines sportives à
découvrir